lo conocieron en el camino y lo apodaron
bob marley su nombre real es marcos
amador y es un hondureño que escapó de
su país el pasado 8 de junio para evitar
que las maras reclutarán a su hijo axel
para adelante para atrás de pagar en
puerta baja a mi hijo
lo quería meter a la mala fuerza y la
verdad las cosas que nosotros siempre
hemos sido personas honradas honestas y
trabajadoras y no acepto eso iba para él
tras salir de honduras marcos y axel
cruzaron guatemala en autobuses hasta
arribar al albergue el buen pastor en
tapachula
[Música]
cuando se siente bien ya salir de su
país porque sabiendo que está peligroso
el país jon morse viene a emigrar aquí
también porque es un poco difícil pasar
lo que no ha pasado
porque hay algo no quieren que no se me
tapan días y uno no quiere eso porque
uno quiere un futuro para su vida
marcos y axel tienen dos opciones para
cumplir su meta de llegar a eeuu esperar
meses mientras se tramita una visa
humanitaria que le otorgue estatus legal
de refugiado o aventurarse en una
caravana de aires de migrantes con la
cual evite ser aprehendido por las
autoridades de migración y ser
eventualmente deportado
marcos le apuesta al trámite de la visa
humanitaria sin importar que el proceso
se demore hasta seis meses en dar frutos
nos acostamos a las dos nos levantamos a
las tres de la mañana y armamos nuestro
grupo que traemos y lo vendimos
caminando ya los vengan los papeles para
cruzar para el otro lado porque esa es
la idea
las solicitudes de asilo en méxico las
otorga la comisión de ayuda para los
refugiados comar un organismo que de las
130.000 peticiones que recibió en 2021
sólo pudo tramitar 38 mil menos del 30
por ciento por lo que para marcos y su
hijo gran parte del sueño americano
dependerá de la suerte